since Donald Trump's election last week
there's been an uptick in the number of
bias based attacks across the nation and
when the latest victims is uh in the New
York City Park memorializing late
beastie boys member adam yauch and adam
yauch Park in Brooklyn Heights was
defaced with graffiti of uh swastikas
and the words go Trump over the weekend
and of course uh yuck like the rest of
the Beastie Boys bandmates was Jewish
the city named the park after the late
rapper in 2013 he died of cancer in 2012
at the age of 47 and the graffiti is
just one of several recent instances of
the Nazi symbol being found around New
York City in other parts of the country
there have been 13 swastika incidents
reported citywide this is just new york
city since november eighth the Southern
Poverty Law Center has updated their
numbers and incidents of hateful
harassment since election day so let let
me talk to you a little bit about this
number the number is 701 there been 701
incidents of hateful harassment reported
to the SPLC or that the SPLC has
gathered or compiled since election day
and people are emailing me and saying
David you're only talking about the Pro
Trump stuff what about the anti-trump
stuff well it is true there were 27 of
these 701 incidents which were actually
anti-trump vandalism graffiti or
harassment so it's important to mention
that but here's what's really important
to mention we can't even get accurate
numbers because many police departments
don't report lots of incidents that are
clearly bias based hate incidents as
such to the FBI so the what really
should be done if you experience or
witness one of these incidences number
one you do call the local police that's
number one but number two you want to
let the local FBI field office know
about the incident ideally give them a
direct police report number that you can
direct them to and number three you also
want to reach out to your local rights
organizations police FBI and civil
rights groups
hopefully it will get on the record
somewhere and I know you're probably
hearing me say this and you're saying
David the right-wingers the trumpets
they don't care about the number of
reported incidents the leaders say that
they're all fake incidents or say that
people deserved it or we'll just ignore
it or not care that may be true but it
is very important that we have these
documented so that then in the future we
actually have a record of what took
place it's not necessarily to convey
convict I'm sorry convince any
particular Trump supporter but we do
want to have accurate data here the same
way that we want to have accurate data
about police shootings and we've talked
about the problems there in getting
accurate data we have a great program
for you today today is kind of a friday
show even though it's wednesday the
wednesday before thanksgiving it's a
friday show format we will be taking
live calls etcetera because we've got
the thanksgiving holiday which will have
us off for the rest of the week so i'm
glad you're here